let's bring in karl rove foxnews
contributor served as senior advisor and
deputy chief of staff to president
george w bush you see all those those
pictures Carl what comes to mind you
have a message for America well I was
honored when I served in the White House
to attend the ceremony each Memorial Day
at Arlington and it's one of the most
moving moments that you could ever
imagine
and I can't begin the day without
thinking of the many families that I met
during my seven nearly seven years in
the White House who had given it of
their own to serve our country and God
bless our country god bless those who
don t in a form of our country and the
families that support them in doing so
it's a remarkable day to remember so
many people and you were on that job
Carl at a time of war too which adds so
much more weight to it as well you're a
patriot we're also talking about the
reopening of our country as we face cope
in nineteen and Carl the Health and
Human Service Secretary Alex a czar was
on Sunday morning Futures yesterday
talking about reopening and how we do it
here's what he had to say thanks to
president Trump's and our governor's
historic response to this we have to and
we can get back to work to school to
community to engagement because it's not
an issue of health versus our economy
it's actually an issue of health versus
health by being locked up in our homes
there's very real health consequences we
have hundreds of thousands of fewer
cancer screenings and treatments going
on we have less preventive services
those are real discernible immediate
health consequences that have to be
considered just as much as the spread of
this disease has to be considered Carl
the president said many times the Cure
can't be worse than the virus are we at
a point where the lockdown especially in
some of these Democrats states where
it's going on and on indefinitely he's
just making the problem worse well I
thought secretary azar made of powerful
point I saw a chart last week of the
decline in so-called elective procedures
18 percent fewer cancer treatments think
about that for a moment
yes we ought to be concerned about kovat
19 we've got to take precautions we've
got them at wear masks we've got to be
engaged in social distancing we have to
wash our hands frequently and we have to
return our country to a place where we
go back to work where people are able to
go to see their doctor where they go to
see it where they go get procedures that
they need and where we begin to restore
the ability of families to take care of
themselves and provide for their for
their future and I thought the secretary
did an excellent job of pointing out
that that if we're smart about it and
worried we practice safe practices that
we can begin to return the country to as
close to normality as COBIT 19 is going
to allow us to do so of course Karl
you're there in Austin Texas and
governor Greg Abbott tweeted this out
about the reopening in your state Texas
is opening safe smart and strong which
prompted former congressman better
O'Rourke to respond to the governor with
this one
dangerous dumb and weak the pandemic is
very political now isn't it
yeah at first I was a little confused I
thought he might be tweeting out his own
personal motto look let's talk about
Texas just for a second the number of
cases and deaths are trending down the
desper capita in the United in Texas are
among the lowest in the United States
where the second most populous state
with 29 million people and we have one
of the lowest per capita death rates in
the country hospitalizations are stating
we have 1500 and 72 people in our
hospitals and with thousands thousands
of available beds so we're doing a good
job of monitor of doing this our bed
capacity is enormous
our testing continues to ramp up we have
tested eight hundred and eighty six
thousand people as of sunday archie b as
of Saturday out of 29 million that means
one out of every 33 Texans has already
been tested and the numbers continue to
go up now what does that really mean let
me give you a comparison and I don't
mean to pick on Pennsylvania but it's
got about it's got less than half the
people in Texas we have 56,000 cases in
Texas we've had 1500 and 33 deaths
unfortunately god bless the each and
every one of them 13 people on Sunday
Pennsylvania which is locked down and
locked down and locked down has 71
thousand
256 cases despite the fact is less than
half the population of Texas 50 145
deaths and 28 people on Sunday so look
and we're in Texas governor Abbott is
right we're treating it safe smart and
strong and I thought it was a cheap shot
by robert Francis O'Rourke to take after
the governor in mr. O'Rourke's own
message he said stay home if you can and
wear a mask well guess what that's
exactly the message of our governor if
you don't need to go out stay at home
and whenever you go out when you go to
work when you go to the store whenever
you move around the community wear a
mask and maintain social distancing but
you know mr. O'Rourke lost a race for
the Senate he he just devastated himself
in a race for for the United States
presidency my son says he's getting
ready to run for governor in a couple
years so he's taking cheap shots
whenever and wherever he can I'd say be
safe smart and strong and stop saying
dangerous dumb and weak things well as
Joe Biden is defending his comments or
facing a lot of backlash about the
comments on black voters you have
Elizabeth Warren he says she's gonna
reportedly host a high-dollar fund
raiser for Biden but who can forget what
she said last year over and over and
over again listen to this
billionaires inline caves should not
pick the next president of the United
States they're oh no to the billionaires
no to the billionaires whether they are
self funding or whether they're funding
PACs we are the Democratic Party and
that's the party of the people
and the big donor stranglehold Carl
what's your reaction well let's be
honest she didn't mean it when she said
those things after all she'd run for the
US Senate a couple of years before
Massachusetts had big dollar fundraisers
had various money from people who had
PACs
took that money and transferred it into
her presidential campaign where she was
making these proclamations of campaign
you know purity and and then she started
her allowed to have started and defended
having her own super PAC so she didn't
mean those things we should know that
Elizabeth Warren is is willing to say
one thing and do another and so we're
gonna we're gonna see it now it looked
let's let's have a list of all of the
big donors who are on the Elizabeth
Warren fundraiser for Joe Biden let's
let have them in transparency let us
know if there are any billionaires or
millionaires among them so that we can
judge whether or not she really meant
what she said when she said those things
earlier I'll tell you it's interesting
to me I don't know who whether the Biden
campaign put it out or Elizabeth Warren
put it out but last week I thought it
was interesting that somebody said Oh
Elizabeth Warren and Joe Biden talk
every week we've already seen him begin
to trim his sales and move left he's
endorsed you know not Medicare for all
but moving towards Medicare for all and
he explicitly said you know Elizabeth
with her criticisms of what I did on
that 2005 bankruptcy bill she was right
and and I would if I could become
president I'm gonna I'm gonna act on her
recommendations about I'm doing what I
did in 2005 I thought that was an
interesting move absolutely well Karl
Rove you were the architect of two
successful runs for the White House yeah
you know what you're talking about we
appreciate your time on this Memorial
Day weekend thank you sir well and and
and and Pete I'd be remiss if I didn't
say I'm grateful for your service to our
country god bless you sir thank you very
much we think of all those today